hola cómo estás estoy ahora en el
problema número 7 en el problema número
7 y estamos en el examen número 6
sección número 9 y bueno este es el
segundo vídeo así que expertos lo
disfrutes y vamos a ponernos a trabajar
así que vamos a darle duro tengo primero
el triángulo rectángulo en este problema
número 7 así que déjame dibujarlo tengo
un triángulo parecido a este ok y es un
triángulo rectángulo y después tengo
otro triángulo parecido por acá que
parece ser un triángulo isósceles y
aunque quién sabe si sea isósceles o no
realmente no nos dicen nada en este
problema pero parece que es un triángulo
isósceles ahora no hay que suponer nada
no es bueno suponer nada en esta vida es
mejor descubrirlo por ti mismo nadie te
da nada gratis así que mejor vamos a ver
qué otros datos nos dan nos dicen que
este es x
en este ángulo de 90 grados y este
aunque parece ser un triángulo isósceles
nos dicen que sus ángulos se llaman 1
b&w no sé si 6 o se es o no pero al
menos así se llaman sus ángulos y dentro
lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale el
promedio de estos cinco ángulos de x
james u v w y como lo que quiero es el
promedio de estos cinco ángulos qué te
parece si nos tomamos a la fórmula del
promedio que es sumar cada uno de los
ángulos x más bien más uno más ven más w
sumar todos estos ángulos y dividirlo
entre la cantidad de datos que me dan
que es 1 2 3 4 y 5 y dividir esto en 3 y
ahora el problema es que esto no está en
soluciones de hecho todas sus soluciones
me dan un valor explícito y me dan un
número así que qué podemos hacer bueno
pues aquí tengo x x más bien es este más
este y puedo saber algo de estos dos
claro son ángulos que suman 90 grados x
más si me fijo en esta parte de aquí
estos dos deben de sumar 90 grados
porque estamos hablando de un triángulo
rectángulo y en un triángulo rectángulo
los dos ángulos que no son el ángulo
recto la suma de ellos es 90 grados o si
no recuerda que lo puedes ver de esta
manera 90 grados que es el ángulo recto
más x más y esto tiene que ser igual a
180 grados porque están adentro de un
triángulo y de aquí podemos ver que x
más bien esto tiene que ser igual a 90
grados entonces lo sustituyó por 90
grados ahora sabremos algo de un wv
w
w claro son agudos está dentro de un
triángulo y si son ángulos que estaban
dentro de un triángulo lo que sabemos es
que la suma de todos los ángulos
internos de un triángulo son 180 grados
es decir que un más ve más w la suma de
estos tres nos tienen que dar 180 grados
porque son ángulos que están adentro de
un triángulo por lo tanto fíjate en
estos tres esté más se esté más esté en
la suma de estos tres me tiene que dar
180 grados esto es lo mismo que 180
grados porque son tres ángulos que están
adentro de un triángulo y ya está
podemos sustituir a cuánto va a ser
igual esto me quedaría 90 más 180 entre
5 no estoy tomando el promedio y esto es
lo mismo que
270 entre 5 y cuántos 273 5
270 lo voy a dividir entre
55 por 5 25 25 de resto estos dos y me
sobran 2
bajos de cero bajo este cero y me queda
45 por 4 es 20 y me sobran 0 es decir
que 273 5 es mismo que 54 el promedio de
estos cinco ángulos
dx10 un wv es 54 grados y ya está el
problema número 7 resuelto no estaba tan
difícil que por cierto estamos en el
éxito a la respuesta de este problema es
el inciso a así que vamos al siguiente
problema voy a borrar todo esto de aquí
y dice ahora tengo una recta numérica
vamos a hacer una recta numérica
tengo una recta numérica parecida a ésta
algo así no está tan difícil de dibujar
a una vez está en américa por aquí y te
además nos dicen que aquí por aquí tengo
a x kubica por aquí tengo a x cuadrada y
por aquí tengo
y dice el problema si x x cuadrada y x
cúbica tienen el orden que se muestra a
continuación 10 esta recta numérica no
cuál de los siguientes podría ser un
valor para x o qué y lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que x tiene
que ser más grande que 0 x tiene que ser
más grande que 0 porque porque x tiene
que ser más grande que 0 pensemos a
claro por qué te parece imagínate que x
algún número negativo se me ocurre
pensar en menos 2 cuánto vale x cuadrada
bueno pues x cuadradas serían menos 4 no
de hecho sería 4 positivo y como todo
número elevado al cuadrado es positivo
excepto en cero
entonces si x fuera negativo x cuadrada
sería más grande que x por lo tanto x
cuadrada tendría que estar por aquí y
sin embargo x cuadrada está antes que x
lo que quiere decir que x tiene que ser
positivo eso importante x tiene que ser
positivo porque si fuera negativo
entonces x cuadrada sería forzosamente
más grande que x y de hecho de igual
manera para 0 si x fuera 0 x cuadradas
de acero y x kubica sería 0 por lo tanto
x no puede ser 0 x tiene que ser más
grande que 0 positivo pero ahora date
cuenta de los siguientes si yo me tomo a
x x como 1 x cuadrada es 1 y entonces
aquí también estoy dando vueltas el
círculo no puede ser 1 y fue algo más
grande que uno si x fuera 20 x 4 adam es
igual a 400 es decir que es mucho más
grande x cuadrada que x si x es un
número más grande que uno fíjate bien si
tuviéramos un número más grande que uno
entonces su cuadrado sería mucho más
grande que x sería por acá y su cubo
sería muchísimo más grande que x
estaremos con por acá por lo tanto x no
puede ser más grande que uno no puede
ser uno no puede ser cero de hecho creo
que x ser forzosamente un número tiene
que ser un número que esté entre 0 y 1
entre 0 y 1 x tiene que ser más grande
que 0 es menor que 1 y quiero que te des
cuenta que tiene toda la razón si yo
tuviera por ejemplo x igual a un medio
entonces el cuadrado de un medio es más
chico que un medio pues el cuadrado de
un medio es un cuarto y un cuarto es más
pequeño que un medio y x kubica x kubica
veamos el cubo de un medio es un octavo
y un octavo es más pequeño que un cuarto
que su vez es más pequeño que un medio
no prefiero como el de la mitad de un
pastel que un cuarto de un pastel que un
octavo de un pastel por lo tanto aquí se
se cumple esto en esta recta numérica
tendremos por aquí el cero y si fuera
por ejemplo x un medio un medio un
cuarto sería más pequeño que x y un
octavo sería más pequeño que x cuadrada
y a su vez que x muy bien por lo tanto
lo que estoy pidiendo es que xe un
número que esté entre 0 y
ok y en todos mis sencillos el único que
es un número que está entre 0 y 1 es el
inciso c perfecto ojo es muy importante
que sepas y que te des cuenta que esto
pasa siempre que tú te tomes un número
entre 0 y 1 y hablamos del problema
número
el problema número 9 que dice lo
siguiente yo tengo un plano cartesiano
así que dibujemos nuestro plato
cartesiano tengo por aquí el eje y tengo
por aquí al eje x vamos a poner que este
es mi eje james este es mi eje x y tengo
una recta que pasa por el origen
tengo una recta que pasa por el origen
justo como esta y además pasa por otro
punto y nos lo dan
me dicen que pasamos por este punto de
aquí que por cierto es el punto
1,313 pasamos por el origen este es el
punto cero coma cero y además pasamos
por el punto h k h coma
y lo que me preguntan es cuánto vale k
entre h cuánto vale cam / a
ok
lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta
es que esta es una recta que está
anclado en el origen por lo tanto si
nosotros sacamos su ecuación su ecuación
sería de la forma y es igual a m por
equis y es más también podríamos sacar
la pendiente la pendiente recuerda que
es el cambio en james con respecto al
cambio en x y aquí como tenemos dos
puntos que si nos dan es decir nos dan
el punto cero cero el origen el punto 13
podemos sacar su pendiente la pendiente
sería el cambio en el cambio en el
estrés entre el cambio en x el cambio el
x es uno es decir que en este caso mi
pendiente es igual a 3 perfecto y ya
teniendo la pendiente que pasa por el
origen podremos decir que esta recta
tiene como ecuación 10 es igual a 3x
esta recta se llama la recta y es igual
a 3 x
lo que yo quiero saber es cuánto vale h
entre cam y cómo me puedo tomar h / k
bueno pues que te parece si construimos
a la pendiente que por cierto ya sabemos
cuánto es la pendiente de este punto y
este punto entre estos dos puntos que me
quedaría bueno pues la pendiente es
igual
0 - k
la diferencia de los valores en james 0
- cam y esto entre 0 -
entre 0 - h la diferencia de los valores
en h es decir lo que cambiamos en ye con
respecto a lo que cambiamos en x y
cuántos esto bueno pues esto es lo mismo
que menos camps entre menos h y aquí
estos dos se mueven positivos esto es lo
mismo que acá entre h ok que es justo lo
que yo quiero pero aquí lo que me dice
es que cante h es exactamente lo mismo a
la pendiente de equipo de tomar esta
parte de aquí en esta parte de aquí me
va a quedar que h / k es lo mismo que la
pendiente ahora lo que está genial es
que esta recta pasa por el punto 0 0 por
el punto 13 pero además pasa por el
punto h como ak h como acá es un punto
que está en esta recta y como está en
esta recta tiene la misma pendiente la
pendiente de la recta es decir que acá
entre h que es lo mismo que m es
exactamente lo mismo en la pendiente de
esta recta qué es
y está la respuesta a este problema es
que acá / h es igual a 3 y ya tengo la
respuesta de este problema número 9
así que tomemos el problema número 10
que tenemos ecuaciones con valor
absoluto y me dicen el valor absoluto el
valor absoluto de m menos 3
esto es igual a 5 ok
también me dan otra ecuación como el
absoluto me dicen que el valor absoluto
de k7
esto es igual a 15
y por otra parte y esto también es muy
importante me dicen que m es menor que
cero y que acá es menor que cero son
números negativos ok y que me pregunten
este problema
cuanto vale m menos acá yo lo que quiero
saber es cuánto vale m menos camps bueno
pues que te parece si trabajamos con
estas dos ecuaciones de acá arriba y
obtenemos el valor de m y el valor de
cam y trabajemos con la primera
actuación voy a trabajar y voy a pensar
en esta ecuación de aquí en esta
ecuación de aquí dice m menos 3 en valor
absoluto es igual a 5 y bueno nosotros
sabemos que esto significa que m - 3 sea
igual a 5 es decir que esto que esté
adentro sea igual a 5 o en su dado caso
o en su dado caso que m - 3 sea igual a
menos 5 que eso de que dentro c igual a
menos 5 porque el valor absoluto de
menos 5 es 5 ok por lo tanto a de aquí
puedo decir que m es igual a 8 si sumo 3
de ambos lados de la ecuación
o en su dado caso m es igual a menos 2 y
sumó 3 ambos lados de la ecuación me va
a quedar que m es igual a menos 2 pero
pero ten cuidado me dicen que es
negativo por lo tanto no puede ser 8 si
me están dando el dato de que me es
negativo m no puede ser 8 porque es un
número positivo entonces no me queda de
otra y me tiene que ser igual a menos 2
el valor de m que cumple que es un
número negativo y además cumple esta
ecuación con valor absoluto es que ms
igual a menos 2 ahora pensemos en la
segunda ecuación en esta ecuación que
tengo aquí dice el valor absoluto de
cama 7 es igual a 15
así que si trabajamos con esta ecuación
que tengo aquí la voy a poner justo acá
esto quiere decir que acá más 7
es igual a 15 o en su dado caso que
llama 7 y 7 no más 3,7 es igual a menos
15 es decir que lo que está dentro del
valor absoluto pues 15 o es menos 15
porque el valor absoluto de -15 es 15 y
de aquí si yo restó 7 de ambos lados de
esta igualdad voy a obtener que ésta es
igual a 8 15 menos 7 sports ok esto por
una parte ahora también aquí puede
restar 7 de ambos lados de ustedes
igualdad y voy a tener que acá es igual
a menos 15 menos 7 es menos 22 menos 22
si debo 15 pesos y después de 27 debo 22
pesos pero de la misma manera yo puedo
cancelar esta opción de cam puede
cancelar este valor de camps porque acá
también es un número negativo me dice
que acá es un número negativo y por lo
tanto el único número negativo que
soluciona esta ecuación es acá igual a
menos 22 es decir que el valor de camps
que cumple esta ecuación de aquí y
además cumple que acá sea negativo es el
valor de acá igual a menos 22 ok ya
tengo a m ya tengo acá porque no lo
sustituimos aquí dice m pero me vale
menos 2 - acá a esto le voy a restar
campero acá vale a menos 22 menos 22 y
yo lo que quiero obtener es el valor de
esto y esto lo mismo que menos 2 más 22
y sea 22 le quitó 2 obtengo 20 es decir
que la diferencia de m menos cam es
igual a 20 que es el inciso en de este
problema número 10 ten cuidado con los
signos no te vayas a equivocar en esto
recuerda que menos por menos me da más y
nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo porque
ya no tengo tiempo para otro problema
así que hasta la próxima